How would you deal with conflict between two team members?
Whenever I come in to a new organization and take up a position as a supervisor,...
...one of the first things I will do is sit down with the team,...
...I will lay out my standards and expectations,...
...and I will say to them,...
..."If you encounter conflict, you should be able to resolve it yourselves initially."
I would then observe what happens moving forward.
And if it quickly becomes apparent that that conflict isn't getting resolved,...
...then I would step in and I would resolve it.
And to achieve that, I would sit down with each of the team members...
...to find out what has happened.
I would never jump to conclusions.
I would ask them questions to get to the bottom of the situation.
And I would then put a plan of action in place...
...to get them to resolve it or I would make the decision for them.
And again, my decision on how I want them to act within their roles...
...would be based on helping the organization achieve its objectives.
So, I have the confidence to deal with conflict quickly.
And if the team members aren't resolving it,...
...then I will certainly step in...
...because  any conflict can have a negative impact on the performance of my team...
...and that would not be acceptable.